Where I come from
the news is being hijacked.
No matter where you turn,
there are characters
where you used to see experts.
Journalism itself has become a scripted reality
show.
But reality is a lot more complex than that.
There are 50 billion shades of gray
it’s not just good vs. evil, us vs. them,
black and white.
And in countries like Russia, China, Turkey
people are told that it’s that simple
the state media want them to believe that.
And if you’re a journalist there
and you’re trying to get beyond that,
to get to the truth
you are facing scare tactics, intimidation
and I wonder: is that where we’re headed
as well?
My responsibility as a journalist is
to get beyond the smoke and mirrors
to get to the truth.
It’s not just about being fair and balanced
or being neutral
it’s about being truthful.